if lowercase X is a member of capital X
Y lowercase Y is a member of set capital
y and lowercase Z is a member of set
capital Z which of the following could
have a value of 23 so let's look at each
of these so x times y times these you're
going to take something from this set
something from this set in something
that from that site and multiply them
together well if you did that you're
going to get a non prime number maybe
you pick one from set X but then you're
going to have to pick a two from set Y
or three or four and then a 345 so
you're going to get things like 1 x 2 x
3 or 1 times 3 times 3 no matter what
especially when you look at these last
two sets you're going to get you're
going to get the product of at least two
primes or you might even take the
product of a composite in a prime or two
composites so there's no way multiplying
those those three especially a member
from these last sets that don't have one
in them that you're going to get a prime
number like 23 23 factors are clearly
only 23 and itself it doesn't have a two
or three or four as a factor doesn't
have a 5 as a factor and so we could
rule that out now let's think about it X
plus y plus Z can we make that equal to
23 so let's see 23 is a lot larger than
these numbers let's see if we pick the
largest number in each of these sets and
see if we can get to 23 so 3 plus 4 plus
5 these are the largest members of each
of those sets and this still only gets
us to 12 so there's no way we're going
to be able to get to 23 now let's see X
plus y times Z X plus y times Z well I
see a way of doing that I see a way of
doing that X plus y times let me do this
in a different color X plus y times Z
what if let's see we can get to 20 by
multiplying 4 times 5 and then you add a
3 so this could be 3 plus 4 times 5 and
so we'll go with that one which of the
following could have a value of 23 that
one and we can only pick one choice so
we know we're already done but we could
verify
we can't get there with these other ones
so let's see x squared plus y squared
plus Z squared this one is tempting it's
tempting just because you could get
numbers large enough but if you play
around enough you would have trouble
finding it finding a combination that
has 2 23 x times y plus Z so there's if
you wanted to get as large as possible
you do 3 times 4 so you could try 3
times 4 and then plus some Z but then in
this case this is going to be 12 plus
z12 + ZZ would have to be 9 you'd have
to find a 9 in this third set there's
clearly no 9 so you could rule that one
out as well so we go at sea